la historia de la zarigüeya Billy estuvo mal,
sobre todo en comparación
con la historia de fondo del oso de peluche.
Piensen en esto: para gran parte de la historia de la evolución humana,
lo que nos resulta impresionante de los osos
es su total independencia de nosotros.
Es que ellos viven esas vidas paralelas
como amenazas y competidores.
Cuando Roosevelt fue de caza a Mississippi,
esa imagen estaba siendo aplastada,
y el animal que estaba atado a un árbol
era un símbolo de todos los osos.
Que esos animales vivieran o murieran
dependía totalmente de la compasión
o de la indiferencia de las personas.
Eso decía algo realmente malo
sobre el futuro de los osos,
pero también decía algo muy inquietante sobre nosotros,
incluso la supervivencia de un animal así
ahora dependía de nosotros.
Así que ahora, un siglo más tarde, si acaso
prestan atención a lo que sucede en el ambiente,
uno siente el malestar mucho más intensamente.
Estamos viviendo una época que los científicos
empiezan a llamar "dependencia de conservación",
y eso significa que hemos devastado
tanto, que la naturaleza quizá ya no pueda valerse por sí sola
y las especies más amenazadas
solo van a sobrevivir
si permanecemos en el paisaje
amarrando el mundo circundante en su favor.
Hemos metido mano
y ya no podemos sacarla,
y eso requiere muchísimo trabajo.
En estos momentos, estamos entrenando cóndores
para que no se posen en los tendidos eléctricos.
Enseñamos a las grullas blancas a emigrar hacia el sur para el invierno
detrás de pequeños aviones ultraligeros.
Estamos ahí vacunando contra la peste de los hurones.
Hacemos seguimiento de conejos pigmeos con drones.
Hemos pasado de aniquilar especies
a la microgestión de la supervivencia de muchas especies
por tiempo indefinido, y ¿cuáles son?
Bueno, esas de las que hemos contado
historias convincentes,
de las que hemos decidido que deberían quedarse.
La línea entre la conservación y la domesticación
es borrosa.
Así que lo que he estado diciendo es que las historias
que contamos sobre los animales salvajes son tan subjetivas
que pueden ser irracionales,
románticas o sensacionalistas.
A veces no tienen nada que ver con los hechos.
Pero en un mundo de dependencia de conservación,
esas historias tienen consecuencias muy reales,
porque ahora, la manera de sentir a un animal
afecta su supervivencia
más que cualquier cosa que uno lea
sobre ecología en los libros.
Ahora importa la narrativa.
Importa la emoción.
Nuestra imaginación se ha convertido en una fuerza ecológica.
Quizá el oso de peluche funcionó en parte
debido a la leyenda de Roosevelt
y aquella osa de Mississippi
fue como una alegoría
de esta gran responsabilidad que la sociedad
estaba empezando a enfrentar en ese entonces.
Pasarían otros 71 años
antes de que se aprobara la Ley de Especies en Peligro de Extinción,
pero, en realidad, aquí está todo su ethos
reducido a algo así como una escena
que uno vería en un vitral.
El oso es una víctima indefensa atada a un árbol,
y el presidente de Estados Unidos
decidió mostrar un poco de misericordia.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
[Ilustraciones de Wendy MacNaughton]